I know who I
am when you finish with you you'll no
longer be
yourself I
remember I remember
everything remembering everything
doesn't mean you know
everything tell me
[Music]
we've just been hacked could be worse
than
Snowden facial recognition got a
hit Jesus Christ that's Jason Bourne why
would he come back
now there's a demonstration in front of
the Greek Parliament building I think
she'll use it as
cover hey attract you we got to
move he's seing things he knows things
what if he's not coming for us what if
it's something
else I volunteered
because of a
lie this is Jason born I need to talk 32
kills people are safer because of what
you
did
[Music]
you're never going to find any peace not
until you admit to yourself who you
really
[Music]
are